do you have that sense though of like
when guys come to date yourself oh I
know what's going on I know you son of a
[ __ ] you're using my sister as a [ __ ]
bag he just
[Music]
he
just
[Music]
this is actually about conjoined twins
all right nothing the rights don't stick
together though oh oh way to think way
to tag that back [ __ ] [ __ ] with this
all right let's go ahead and just get
some contextual photos because I think
conjoined twin photos are very very fun
to look at
oh I like them dude I follow them yeah
oh I yeah
this one is a hilarious this one right
here is hilarious the one on the I was
gonna say I was like dude I was like how
did she move but it was because the
photo oh God my dad there it is there it
is okay
they share do they share the same torso
oh okay yeah I'll get into the details
chest two yeah yeah and dude they're
hilarious have you seen them no dude
they are hilarious Instagram yeah they
don't shy away from any questions they
like make you feel stupid for asking the
dumbest questions that's tired they were
so yeah dude they were like ripping on
people that asked like the dumbest
questions what's a dumb question you
would ask like like
how do you guys use the restroom this
and that things like that stupid things
like how do you guys share this like how
the [ __ ] do you think we share it was
like we're sharing one [ __ ] body here
like did she annoy you like no she can't
annoy me even if she did she's like
we're stuck together like Max question
like she just answered I don't know
anything different right yeah because
that's what they're saying because
they're like some people are like I feel
so bad for you I'm so sorry it's just
like for what I don't know any
difference yeah this is sick if anything
like I think like your life sucks like
you know her life this well that's how
we know so they're really cool so they
actually just uh you know opened up
about how one of them managed to meet
her boyfriend that's cool their names
are Carmen and Lupita Andrade age 21 uh
they were on a YouTube ask me anything
where the twins answer people's
questions and stuff like that about
their very very unique lives how did
they had that relationship yeah they
they admitted uh at the start of the
interview that most people haven't met a
set of conjoined twins before and they
said they're connected at the Torso and
share of pelvis okay um they then stress
they have two separate Hearts they don't
share a brain obviously however there
are multiple parts of their body these
are entwined including their Digestive
and reproductive systems interesting so
they both have to like the one guy
go ahead everybody take a beat think
about it for you do they have one
that's the that's the burning questions
that everybody should ask no one asked
them I I don't know if they would answer
I don't know because if they they should
because that was okay you said they
share reproductive reproductive system
and a pelvis okay probably they have
what yeah they have one so that okay so
here okay so so okay I'm gonna say
something go for it we might get flagged
oh believe in yourself do they uh
why is that a bad thing to ask because
it's like uh I'm just adding feel to the
flame uh to me it would be like if the
girl is like you know doesn't want to
is it consensual
like is it cheating is it is it cheating
both of them have to like because they
both have to be like you know what we
have to be cool with this
it's obviously something that How would
how would a human being not think about
those things and not be curious to those
questions I think it's totally natural
to to think about that if you're opening
the platform to ask questions so do they
both feel the orgasm that's what I'm
saying so it's actually let's just say
it man it's a step even like before
significant steps before that we'll get
that they do say their own sides are
their own sides when it comes to
physical Sensations but again that is
shared down there right
um
it's interesting so this is like when
you like feel your own leg but it's your
it's just because they have two spinal
cords yeah it feels or like I don't know
if it's too funny yes technically
because it goes up to them so she blows
her own legs yeah or the if they shake
hands they not then they don't feel
their own hand right well you feel your
hand when you're shaking hands yeah but
they said that their own side is their
own like they don't feel it maybe maybe
right so what we got maybe what
receptors are are firing with from like
a nerve ending point like if it was
connected to it and what does what do
they share the reproductive system and
they're being tested so if they get a
stomach ache they both feel it we
shouldn't have ate that yesterday yeah
that's probably really convenient though
eat some Thai Spice and then the other
one doesn't and then she's like [ __ ]
why did you [ __ ] eat that spices
and can one skip a meal and then the
other one eats for them what if one's
dieting and the other one's not bro
right what if they're like trying to be
a bodybuilder and one's like stabbing
all that candy man we're trying to get
above I know she just wakes up and her
arm is getting swollen God damn
you're buffing me
up
keep going just keep going well you put
me on a spot like that yeah yeah I want
to roll man [ __ ] the most fascinating
question is when a conjoined twin gets a
significant other like that is by far
the most fastest I feel like I watched
the movie where there was one yeah stuck
together and then they had to like make
a wall yeah Matt Damon yeah or something
right yeah they had it like a little it
was a documentary yeah that movie
Denzel Washington yeah Denzel Washington
so I mean we're thinking about it
briefly so just from the perspective of
them but what about the the man who's
interested in them if he's he must have
been like two for one baby yeah he was
uh I don't mean I get two girls right I
was following them on
kind of huh right it's two legs I was
following him on like Instagram or like
a tick tock and he just looked so nerdy
that he he looked like he's like the kid
that would bring like Pokemon cards to
like a party and just be like yo what's
up who's that guy y'all trying to trade
so he was just very like not even
thinking I didn't think he thought like
things like that he was just focusing on
just Pokemon yeah Pokemon's just very
nerdy and I remember going like oh he's
not that type of dude like you can just
tell like I can just sense it when
you're like I know your [ __ ] true
intentions oh yeah and here's the true
intentions were like I got a holographic
[ __ ] Charizard
um that's like worth a lot of money oh
God he's like a really good investor in
the future thank you thank you Julie
it's a holographic charger don't you
know that collecting Pokemon cards are
cool holy crap nerd alert it's called
investing you should have said like a
Snorlax or something you know what it is
dude you know what it is with me at
Pokemon dude is it's tangible don't be a
hater yeah I got Trauma from the Pokemon
you know what I mean that's why that's
where truth comes out did you get picked
on for having fun yes I got picked on
for opening up my little folder and
having the whack as cards are like dude
look at look at this guys I'm like what
no no I had a cool card you should
[ __ ] feed the mom be like what the
[ __ ] you talking about dude stick up to
your hobby well sometimes they just
close my book and ran away well look
like
that ran this is terrible I hope you
still have it it could probably worth a
lot of money now I have a little stack
and I have rubber band on it and stuff
the only coolest thing I've ever had
that I was like holy and people were
like oh it was uh uh [ __ ] that muscle
guy what the [ __ ] is his name the
stretch guy not Jill dude right no no
champ yes my champ and it was a
holographic one is it the one with the
big ones and in the bars on a blast
Blastoise and then that was a
holographic too that's a huge one yeah
no I remember it was like who Shield you
get that that's up there with [ __ ]
Venusaur better look up the value you
want that yeah yeah I still have it it's
if it's mint you know what I mean you
got to get that [ __ ] appraised yeah
foreign
is asexual and aromantic to answer your
guys's concerns and questions what's
that mean that creates a lot of problems
what is that okay well you're about to
find out so that means Carmen revealing
that she's been dating her current
boyfriend for about a year and a half
explains that they met off hinge I'll
build this slowly because we like
foreplay they met off hinge sometimes
all I get is foreplay she said it was
really awkward to reveal that she was a
conjoined twin on her dating profile so
did she was there a hinge profile she
didn't include her sister I would assume
that the photo probably just was her
it's a hard Miss though you can't yeah
you ain't four nobody bro come on she
said I was obviously going to be
transparent about everything it was a
learning process for everybody we
obviously had to have a discussion on
what boundaries are okay and what aren't
would that be considered catfish like
between the three of them or like well
it has to be with three that's the thing
right right but like but I'm just saying
like if they're into talking stations on
hinge and she didn't reveal that she was
a conjoined she did she did reveal I
guess via the conversation yeah there's
no way to like hold that back imagine
one more conversation it's coming Hi how
are you doing I have a conjoined yeah
but imagine her like doing that without
telling her like by the way I did
something like what
I am on a date I'm going on a date
tomorrow
what do you mean yes we're gonna meet
you
my other thumb was typing in response
like what is that if I was there with
you I saw she was [ __ ] watching
Netflix or the only ones while we were
hiding away and [ __ ] you only got one
hand remember only one hand on that side
oh do they share no they got two hands
yeah no but the other one has the other
hand how are you gonna hide no that's
not how it is their hands dude I thought
they have four hands there's two you see
she has her other hand in the back that
looks like a dude look it again I've
seen their videos they have two hands
they don't have their own hands he's a
fan no dude you said it I didn't say it
no no no I didn't say I don't know what
happened she was talking about the
[ __ ] guy with the forearms okay the
Mortal Kombat guy Dr Octagon Dr Octagon
anyways they got their own hands one
thing about Goro they don't have they
don't have four hands I thought they'd
just share feet I think it's just the
feet that they're sharing anyways they
got their hands to get to the last
question they actually says
my brain [ __ ] hurts she she implied
that she and her boyfriend are not
intimate sexually because of her
situation as a conjoined twin we're not
intimate in that way and he's okay with
that right everyone wins you see he's
not you were right about him I told you
yeah I could just sense in the guy
because you know maybe he's asexual I'm
my sister's boyfriends I can see him and
I'm like I know what's up dude I know
what's going on I know where they're
going I know they're not going to
[ __ ] bowling no hey some people just
want companionship you know I mean they
just want a partner she technically has
no no but like opposite sex bro opposite
sex she wants a man's touch I don't know
yeah I don't know you want to hold hands
with a man sometimes me too being are
you big brother or
um little big brother do you have that
sense though of like when guys come to
date yourself oh I know what's going on
I know you son of a [ __ ]
you're using my sister as a [ __ ] bag he
just wants to pay
no anyways but yeah I could just sense
when the guy's just like bad news I'm
like [ __ ] this is all he wants and
she's like what if I want that too like
oh you're a [ __ ]
[Music]